bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bonjour gabriel lordinot bonjour bonjour
merci de me recevoir
alors le président de la ligue de
natation de la martinique que vous êtes
à a lancé un cri du coeur
passionné et outré sous la forme d'une
lettre ouverte aux élus de la cacem
alors passionné pour la cause de la
jeunesse et du bien-être de notre
jeunesse
et puis outre et gabriel lordinot par
une demande auprès de la ligue de
natation d'une somme de 8000 euros
c'est ça qui s'ajoute à une autre somme
précédente
expliquez-nous oui je suis président de
cet organe cette association depuis plus
de 25 ans et jamais jamais nous n'avons
payé la moindre somme pour gagner une
compétition sur tous les bassins de
martinique y compris le lamentait
lorsqu'il était dirigé par creux
l'office des sports et ne voilà-t-il pas
que bâtiments dont nous avons rêvé
nouveaux bassins que nous avons souhaité
que nous avons soutenu que nous avons
accompagné pour sa réalisation
vous parlez du santal qu assistante
aquatique de la caceres de la castille
implanté au lamentin oui nous avons fait
des interventions auprès de la
fédération pour accompagner ce projet au
niveau du sud du cnds et puis ne courait
vous dites que de devenir le cauchemar
ici c'est désolant
alors pour qu'on comprenne bien on vous
on vous demande alors la cacem à donne
une délégation de service public à l'ucp
ah c'est ça qui est l'union des centres
de sport en plein air je crois c'est sa
chute oui c'est ça alors c'est lui cpa
qui gère cette piscine ce centre
aquatique du lamentin pour la cacem et
vous recevez une mise en demeure dites
vous de la part de ce délégataire l'ucp
à une mise en demeure de payer plus de
8000 euros pour la tenue des
compétitions de natation de la saison
2015 2016
une somme qui s'ajoute à 14 1400 euros
réclamés pour l'organisation des carifta
donc ça fait une vingtaine de milliers
d'euros qu'on vous réclamant tous pour
avoir organisé des des compétitions
de haut niveau ici en martinique
parenteau puisque nous avons un pays
4000 euros de location de la ligne d'eau
pour pouvoir utiliser la piscine c'est
tout à fait normal
nous avons payé 2000 euros pour la wii
donc il ya encore de l'essonne qui sera
ville pour faire apprendre à nager aux
jeunes leurs difficultés
et tout cela nous sommes d'accord mais
ce que nous n'acceptons pas c'est de
payer pour les compétitions
ça ne s'est jamais fait je veux pas
créer un précédent et dire oui d'accord
ça y est on paye pour les compétitions
les autres villes de la martinique
boudiba temps sur ce cap et la paix
c'est à dire que ça peut créer un
précédent seul un fâcheux précédent
tafer et les autres peuvent s'engouffrer
dans l'app store
le cpa ce que elle est dans son droit
est ce que c'est les gars vous faites
allusion à une convention que vous avez
signé pour donc votre présence pour
l'utilisation de cet outil qui est le
centre aquatique de la cacem oui l'ulm
gta n'est pas en cause la cacem avait
parfaitement le droit de déléguer la
gestion de son bien à un organisme quel
qu'il soit mais la cacem a mis en place
des tarifs et c'est dingue c'est de la
compétence de la cacem il y avait un
cahier des charges qui avant même
l'ouverture du bassin été mis en place
un cahier des charges qui dit quoi il
dit qu' il y aura des heures réservées
pour les compétitions mois qu ici
d'étudier le français jeudi déjà réservé
pour les compétitions chouette alors on
aura donc des heures mises à notre
disposition pour les compétitions et des
administrations enfants d'une mise à
disposition gratuitement pc ce que je
crois puisque c'est ce qui se fait par
ailleurs autrement autrement pourquoi on
aurait 2 un cahier des charges signalées
qui auraient des heures pour les
compétitions à se m'ont dit si
jamais je dis pas ce quota de la bien je
jouais ap je jouais plus la possibilité
de dépasser ce quota d'heures non c'est
pas possible
donc nous disons que nous voulons que
cahier des charges soit respectée il ya
des administratifs qui disent oui mais
c'était pas écrit que c'était gratuit
donc c'est payant je n'admets pas cela
et au nom de tous ces jeunes que nous
nous entourant bénévolement au nom de
tous ces jeunes je dis non à ces il faut
quand même permettre que la tenue des
compétitions surtout que pousser pendant
ces compétitions le centre n'est pas
fermé contrairement aux autres bassins
qui nous accueille au lorrain h el
cheikh où françois ou ailleurs à sainte
marie le bassin est fermé comme dans les
compétitions là les activités continuent
normalement alors c'est pour ça que vous
dites que si vous ne payez pas les
sommes qui vous sont demandées
il n'y aura pas de préjudice financier
pour le centre aquatique que préjudice
financier et puis alors qu'est ce que
c'est cette gestion de nos sportifs
j'ai une gestion plus au moins comptable
on dit bon mais il faut payer les gros
sous il faut il faut offrir des recettes
à tout court à tout prix même pour une
compétition qui n'est qu'il se fait sans
recette
les parents viennent ils accompagnent
nos enfants la natation est un sport
difficile il faut pour être performant
s'entraîner à au moins 21 venus au parc
par semaine deux fois par jour après
tous ces sacrifices qu'ils font dans le
bassin on pense que les clubs et tout le
monde paye pour pouvoir utiliser basset
et je dis que c'est normal sauf que les
tarifs soient un peu chaud mais enfin
c'est normal je dis qu'il faudrait quand
même permettre la tenue de ces
compétitions
alors vous avez fait allusion ou
caritatives temps nous avons une
négociation avec la cacem jeudi avec la
casse mais plutôt avec des
administratifs n'ont jamais eu en face
de nous les élus etc administratif nous
ont dit qu'il est interdit de nous
mettre à disposition gratuitement
l'équipement polygraphe tard je ne
comprends pas ça j'ai demandé des textes
que j'ai jamais vu mais on nous a
demandés labo 60000 euros dit niet
on va demander 42000 d'amandine y est on
est descendu et nous avons signé pour
14400 que nous allons payer mais là
dessus nous pensions et j'ai dit au
président lors de la signature de la
convention devant un parterre de témoins
président je ne signe que si vous me
promettez de menou signé une convention
pour mettre à disposition gratuitement
cet équipement pour nos compétitions
alors on a l'impression parce que votre
rappelle que votre lettre ouverte
s'adresse aux élus de la cacem donc là
vous demandez vous avez eu des contacts
vous avez négocié avec des
administratifs et vous demander aux élus
donc de se saisir de cette affaire
oui mais tout à fait au nom de je le
disais on nous invente retient au nom du
bien être là the largest martiniquais
n'est absolument pas ce que nous avons
dit tous les projets que nous avons et
il nous faut des bassins lorsqu'on
construit un bassin comme celui là qui
rayonne sur toute la caraïbe c'est pas
pour le reste est fait pour le garder
fermées il y a eu des deux pointes et
revenant par exemple la ligue du sport
d'entreprise qui a eu besoin de cet
équipement peau des championnats eh bien
ils ont payé mon bon là aussi il y avait
un projet de nage avec palmes et qui
voulaient se fait à la main ils ont
renoncé parce qu'elles ont trouvé qu'il
y avait je pensais que la ja quoi il ya
un peu un esprit d'âpreté financière de
d'un effet d'aubaine voilà constamment
sur le dos des jeunes nageurs et de leur
entourage non mais c'est comme si on
demandait un lycée d'être rentable c'est
comme si on demandait à une école alors
vous insistez sur l'utilité publique de
d'une manière générale nous a fait c'est
de faire des compétitions sportives et
c'est un service public oui c'est au
service public et nous souhaitons qu
effectivement là on puisse avoir une
autre gestion que cette gestion purement
comptable qu'on puisse de se dire tiens
il ya actuellement a fait aussi au lac
arrive c'était le cas des carifta nous
aurons bientôt en novembre prochain les
championnats de l'eau et c est ce qui
nous ont été attribués là encore il va
falloir faire tout un débat pour essayer
d'avoir
leuba s'est alors rapidement il nous
reste une minute juste savoir si alors
votre lettre ouverte date de quelques
jours peut-être une semaine après vous
avez eu des nouvelles de la part des
élus de la cacem du président ou de non
pas tant que ça va pas tarder mais moi
je me promets de prendre mon bâton de
pèlerin de faire le tollé mère j'ai déjà
rencontré le maire de shellshock m'a
promis son soutien
je vais voir le maire de fond le fier
membre du bureau de l'acca sawiris
président et je vais voir le meilleur du
lamentait le maire de chez de
saint-joseph je le connais c'est le
président nous allons les revoir tenter
de les voir puisque je demande par une
audience qui ne vient jamais donc nous
ne sommes pas et contre l'isi et nous
sommes pour défendre les intérêts de
notre jeune et très bien et de notre
côté nous tâcherons aussi d'avoir leur
leur réponse en tout cas sur cette
saisine que vous faites auprès des élus
de la caserne sous la forme de cette
lettre ouverte vraiment en quelques mots
c'est assez symbolique aussi de la
difficulté qu'il ya d'une manière
générale à organiser ce type de grandes
compétitions comme les carifta de
natation à l'échelle de la grande région
ici en martinique c'est ça c'est
symbolique aussi de difficultés y
compris dans le transport faire venir
les légendes et c'est vrai que ce n'est
pas mission impossible nous avons réussi
des caractères grâce au savoir-faire de
gens qui savent organiser notamment nous
avions robert marengo avec nous qui a
organisé plusieurs qu'aux cyclistes mais
je dis que là pour pouvoir réaliser
cette ouverture sur la carie nous avons
besoin des élus et c'est pourquoi nous
les appelons ce coup pour le mode et de
sauver notre jeunesse
parce que si jamais c'est pas réglé
banian risque qui est plus du tout
devrait bien se passer a droit il va
servir surtout que déjà les écoles
niveau plus pense que c'est trop cher
points merci gabriel lordinot d'avoir
participé à ce qu'a dit on ce mercredi
matin vous êtes le président de la ligue
de natation de la martinique maintenu
ainsi